hello everybody and welcome to our TGS
2015 presentation of Metal Gear Online
the online multiplayer mode familiar
Solid 5 the phantom pain we know that
many players have been waiting a long
time for info on MgO so it gives us
great pleasure to reveal for the first
time ever an in-depth look at some of
ngo's new features including classes
mission types abilities and equipment
hopefully people have been enjoying
Metal Gear Solid V the phantom pain
since it launched earlier this month and
maybe a few of you have even cleared the
main story mode if so then you'll feel
right at home
email your online as the game uses the
exact same control scheme and much of
the same equipment but in a competitive
online setting and as promised MgO will
go live and be free to download on
October 6th for everyone who owns mega
Solid 5 the phantom pain so let's go
ahead and start the game
for your player character you can choose
the avatar that you created at the
beginning of motor solidfire's have the
pain or you may also create new
characters if you wish
character creation system is incredibly
deep with many options as you can see
here and if we wanted we could take all
day tweaking things but for now let's go
ahead and go with this next you choose
your characters specialty from the
following three classes scalp enforcer
or infiltrator let's take a quick look
at what each of these classes can do
infiltrators excel in close range combat
they're very quick on their feet and
they can be very lethal when paired with
stealth camo here we see an infiltrator
sneaking up behind an enemy to
interrogate them and extract the
location of opposing team members
naturally you can also sneak up on
enemies and kidnap them using the Fulton
as well long story short if stealth is
your thing then the infiltrator class is
the one for you
next up is the Scout class the scout is
well balanced and can be effective at
both combat and support roles Scouts
excel at spotting enemies from a
distance allowing you to quickly mark
enemies for your allies then support
them is long-range sniper fighter my
tagging from a distance minimizes the
risk of being spotted or attacked by the
enemy so if you're the type who likes to
gather Intel and snipe targets then this
would be the perfect class for you and
finally we have the enforcer class the
enforcer is a heavily put class that
excels at combat the forces have high
stamina and excel it using a variety of
heavy weapons these guys are tanks to
take a good amount of damage before
going down so it's perfect for players
who prefer to dive straight into the
enemy lines
all right so now that we've explained
the classes let's jump into an actual
mission
there are several mission types to
choose from but for today we'll
introduce you to the boundary under
mission the premise is fairly
straightforward all you have to do is
eliminate as many enemy players as you
can however this rule set features some
dynamic twists that make matches very
unpredictable and even players to
quickly turn the tide of battle with
strategic play at the top left of the
screen you can see the map and next to
it you see the remaining tickets both
your team and the enemies team whenever
you kill or Fulton recover an enemy a
ticket is subtracted from the toll if
the enemies tickets are reduced to zero
your team widths
and these yellow marks indicate bounty
points a bounty point gets added every
time we defeat an opponent in other
words opponents who have very high
bounty points have defeated many of your
allies if you Fulton the enemy rather
than killing them their bounty points
are added to your team's ticket total
this means that if you defeat enemies
that have a high bounty you can quickly
flip the balance of the match right so
let's start the mission
heading your way alright so the names of
your comrades are displayed in blue
above their head and what you're seeing
right now is the salute action saluting
a teammate can establish a buddy link
with them among other things becoming
buddies with another player allows for
sharing of information for example you
can see if your buddy is aiming at as
indicated by the blue laser you see on
the screen
aside from this other actions can also
be enabled as you build more camaraderie
with your buddy split up
let's take a look at some of your other
teammates red markers on the screen are
the opposing team and note that markers
placed by your allies are shared with
the entire team
erepair players are entering the
building as a tuning cell and an enemy
was detected firefight ensues response
this vicious box which was empty
and it turns out as a trap because we
have a sleep mine and the enemy was
actually a stealth camo and is now
taking us hostage but as you can see one
of our teammates matches course sniper a
shot on the eye and save us thanks to
our buddy there all right so now we're
going to take the view of the sniper and
we see some of our teammates down below
so see if you'll lend a hand
let's scope out the area and see from
provide some cover fire oh but no it's a
dreaded plush snare anyone who looks at
it as a realm bites cuteness and will be
unable to move even if it's just through
binoculars that snipers now disabled
but there's a nice shield - by one of
our other teammates we'll go ahead and
pull to the enemy and take their tickets
and establish a new buddy later hope
that buddy links can be re-established
and changed at any time
all right in the meantime let's see what
some of the other teammates are up to it
looks like we're announcing a dear
nothing bad I need trouble
my son but looks like we were hit by a
fulton cannon no teammates around save
us were immediately removed from the
field and it meanwhile one of our
infiltrators is making good use of
stealth camo to capture an interrogation
opposing team member this enables you to
automatically mark opponents and share
the location with the rest of the team
and on the bridge we see our guys are
being pushed back by our Walker gear but
we're too far to offer support in cases
like this you can use a bit of
technology that may look familiar from
the main game what we did is we use a
wormhole since we transport ourselves to
our base locations
the enemy didn't notice us let's hijack
their Walter near and even the score
all right and I Walker here was hit
and it looks like is that guy in the red
beret from before work ma'am reveals
that he is a huge bounty on his head and
our infiltrator was hit by a missile but
if we can Fulton this guy in the red
beret before time runs out we can
instantly turn the battle round and win
the match
it's not much time left and the blue
team is dangerously low on tickets at
this rate we will lose so we need to
open this guy before time runs out
and we're hit by stun grenade that's not
good
help me out
but our comrade rescues us and with a
well-timed Fulton punch we can instantly
Fulton the guy in the red beret turning
his bounty into blue tickets just as
time runs out and James solid wins in an
amazing upset job well done and that
concludes the mission for today but
before we end today's presentation we'd
also like to give you a quick peek at
another exciting feature of MgO unique
characters as teased previously Ocelot
is playable in MgO and aside from being
able to dual wield revolvers he can also
use Ritchie shots to hit targets that
aren't in his direct line of fire
allowing him to hit enemies even if
they're taking cover
pretty good huh no but wait was that our
remote control yes snake also makes his
appearance in MgO complete lose bionic
arm which gives them Baris unique
abilities such as the ever-popular
rocket punch
well done boss alright and that
concludes our TGS 2015 presentation of
Metal Gear Online players can look
forward to discovering other stages
mission types equipment and abilities
for themselves when MgO goes live next
month on October 6th
Bell Gear Online is the competitive
multiplayer component for Metal Gear
Solid 5 the phantom pain and will be
freely available for everyone who owns
the game so mark your calendar and be
sure to download the update when it goes
live
service begins on Tuesday October 6th
Pacific Standard Time use the remaining
time to clear the single-player missions
brush up on your skills in preparation
for MgO
thank you for watching